Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und ich werd's mal auf Twitter posten.
Haha, geile Message, äh, Alter.
Guck mal.
Hab ich grad auf Twitter gelesen.
Ich wurde auf Instagram gesperrt, weil ich meine eigenen Freunde oder ihre Bilder beleidigt hab.
Weil es jetzt gar nicht so irgendwie...
Wahrscheinlich war es jetzt eher im Spaß gemeint, geh ich mal voraus.
Die schlagen halt manchmal echt ein bisschen über die Stränge.
So.
Post das mal schon auf Twitter.
Äh, übrigens hier, guck mal. Wir haben Twitch Emotes.
Twitch Emotes.
Sollen wir mal ein bisschen Cringe Song anmachen.
So, ich wollte Twitter posten.
Twitch Emotes.
Ich bin ja begeistert, dass um die Uhrzeit auch schon Leute da sind.
Wir machen heute auch keinen, keinen Brogers.
Wir spielen ein bisschen was. Ich hab nämlich ein Review gesehen zu einem Game, das wollte ich unbedingt mal ausprobieren.
Hab ich gesagt, komm, scheiß drauf, machst du einfach mal an.
Eigentlich wollte ich ein bisschen aufräumen heute, aber ich hatte jetzt die Auswahl.
Was spielen und stremsorn.
Ja, ist gut, halt die Klappe.
Ich hatte jetzt die Auswahl zwischen stremsorn und was spielen oder aufräumen.
Wow.
Und da hab ich mich natürlich fürs Aufräumen entschieden, wie ihr euch denken könnt, ne.
So, ähm, ja, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr aufgefallen ist, wir haben Twitch Emotes.
Allerdings ist das gefakte, gefakte Twitch Emotes, die wir hier in unserem Chatboard haben.
Denn ich hab mir gedacht, warum soll ich den selbst programmieren,
wenn ich mir einfach einen Browser Plugin installieren kann, was mir einfach jeglichen Text zu Twitch Emotes macht.
So, ich glaube Twitch hat jetzt gecheckt, dass der Stream on ist.
Wollen wir mal anfangen, wir haben Quality Options, nice.
Tollen Stream, das muss ich erst mal zeigen, ob das Game was traucht, mal schauen.
So, ich hab's mir gekauft auf GOG.
Und ich hab's, ich bin schon mal ins Game rein, hab Settings eingestellt und hab wieder ausgemacht.
Auf GOG hab ich's gekauft.
Weggegockt hab ich sozusagen das Game.
Das ist Massive Big Brain.
Weggegockt ist unglaublich, ey, das musst du dir merken, das ist so ein dummer Spruch, ey.
Wenn man ein Spiel auf GOG kauft, heißt es ab jetzt, es ist weggegockt.
Das ist richtig dumm, ey.
Ich muss schon aufschreiben, das ist so dumm.
So, schauen wir mal, ob das was taugt, ich bin mal gespannt.
Das ist so ein bisschen, also ich hab ein Review-Video geguckt, das hat ein bisschen was von Quake 2.
So ungefähr.
Ach ja Leute, übrigens, ich hab jetzt ja hier im Hintergrund mal ein neues Tool laufen, ja.
Und das lockt alle Fragen mit, die Ed Wupplos in der Frage haben, ja.
Und wenn quasi Ed Wupplos im Chat drin ist, dann wird das hier mit gelockt, das heißt ich übersehe keine Fragen mehr.
So, wenn ich die Frage dann beantwortet hab, kann ich die hier löschen.
Das ist das Pepega Board, das ist für die vergesslichen Leute.
Ich mein, ich bin nächsten Monat, Leute, nächsten Monat bin ich 35, kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, oder?
Jo, Max, hab gleich Zeugnisvergabe, fange im August dann meine Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration an.
Ohne dich wüsste ich hundertprozentig nicht, was ich nach der Schule hätte machen sollen.
Aber du hast mir Technik-Artikel über die Jahre seit 2012 und i.
So mit meinem, näher gebracht. Ja, das ist schön, ich hoffe dir gefällt das.
Ich hoffe dir gefällt das.
In welchem Bereich ist die Firma, wo du dann hingehst?
Darf man das wissen?
Also du musst jetzt nicht die Firma reinschreiben, so einfach nur, was das ist, irgendwie Bank, Finanzdienstleister, Support, Hotline-Dudes.
Der Moon Eater Baku schreibt, ich bin todtraurig.
Ohje, was ist was jetzt los?
Ok, Moment, da muss John nochmal die passende Musik dazu nochmal anmachen.
Ok, warum? Also.
Habe zwei Jahre einen meiner App gearbeitet, schreibt er, diese war auch beliebt und jetzt habe ich meinen PC neu aufgesetzt.
Und alle Daten sind weg, die Sicherungen in der Klasse sind mir aus, unbegreiflich, ich könnte einen Monat zurück so viel verlieren.
Das sagt ein weiterer Grund, warum man das am besten in irgendeine Git Repo eincheckt und pusht.
Aber ich kenne das, ich habe auch schon Zeug verloren, jeder.
Und die Leute, die am größten erzählen, immer Backup machen, ich meine, ich bin nicht auch so verfecht davon.
Die machen auch nicht vor allem Backup.
Das ist das aber Mist, was war es denn für eine App?
Was war es denn für eine App?
Ich hoffe, wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, ob der Sound nicht zu laut ist.
Und wie die Quali ist, müssen wir schauen.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt 1080p, 48 FPS.
Das Spiel hat nicht, so wie ich es gesehen habe, nicht die aller krasseste Textur-Off-Lösung und alles Mögliche.
Aber mal gucken, es ist halt relativ schnell, es ist relativ schnell.
Deswegen müssen wir schauen, ob es hängt.
Wow, was jetzt?
Alter, warum hängt das, warum rockelt das so?
Das liegt bestimmt an Gok.
Also Glück hast du Freie, nice.
Wow.
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen laut, hä?
Bisschen laut, Leute.
Wir gehen erst mal ins Game rein und gucken mal.
Eine Community mit über 14K Downloads im App Store.
Oh, das ist nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Android oder iOS?
Weil ich meine, vielleicht kannst du dir, wenn es eine Android-App ist,
kannst du dir den Kram vielleicht wieder irgendwie aus dem APK so ein bisschen zurückbrusten.
Ich weiß nicht, habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Müsste gehen.
Also die Apps aus dem Android Play Store kann man auf jeden Fall ein bisschen,
also das ganze Java-Zeug zumindest, wieder ein bisschen zurückumwandeln.
Man kriegt mal keinen schönen Sauce-Code raus, das ist klar.
Aber ich habe es gesehen, irgendein Typ, also das Shield TV hat keinen ordentlichen Browser.
Also hier das da, das Nvidia Shield TV hat keinen ordentlichen Browser,
aber das ist ein ziemlich gutes Teil zum Mediacenter für ein Fernseher.
Und das hat aber halt keinen ordentlichen Browser.
An sich ist die Plattform gut, das heißt, ich habe mal geguckt, was es gibt
und irgendein Typ hat vom Firestick, hat er den Silk-Browser vom Firestick genommen,
die kompiliert und dann ein paar Sachen geändert,
dass er auf anderen Geräten auch läuft und hat es wieder hochgeladen als APK.
Ah, hast schon probiert.
Es ist Mist, ich habe auch schon einige Sachen verloren, weil ich es nicht gespeichert habe.
Das sackt.
Einmal hatte ich übelst Glück, da habe ich auch, das war so die Zeit,
wo ich immer ganz gerne mal Windows neu installiert habe.
Und ich hatte es glücklicherweise, ich hatte damals schon ein iMap-Postfach,
ich habe es mal jemanden per Mail geschickt und da war es nur eine Woche alt.
Das waren Zeiten, wo man auch Sachen per Mail verschickt.
Übrigens, wer immer noch einen POP3-Postfach hat, der muss unbedingt iMap beste.
So, ich gucke mal, ob der meine Settings behalten hat.
Ich schaue das Epic Anti-Alasing an, bin mir nicht sicher, ob Anti-Alasing in dem Game etwas taugt.
Ich finde, es sieht eher verschwommen aus.
Müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Blablabla, so, Settings.
Hat er meinen FOF behalten? Wichtigste.
FOF95, jawoll.
Quest.
Campaign.
Story, wer braucht Story? Scheiß auf Story.
Alter, Skip. Keine Story.
Äh.
Moment mal.
Mit der Auflösung stimmt aber irgendwas nicht.
Oder?
Nice. Nice.
Stimmt was mit der Auflösung? Die Auflösung sieht komisch aus.
Warum hat sich das denn nicht umgestellt?
Borderless, Accept. Bam.
So, besser.
So, mal gucken, ob das etwas taugt. Ich bin aber wirklich gespannt.
Also, das Review-Video, was ich gesehen habe, war ultra nice.
Hard, Difficult. Okay, was gibt's?
Was gibt's für ein Schwierigkeitsgrad? Selection.
Easy, Medium.
Oh, da ist noch was.
Da ist noch was.
Oder ist das einfach nur Fake?
Da hinten ist noch was.
Aber es könnte ja sein, dass man, falls da hinten noch ein Schwierigkeitsgrad ist,
gibt's bestimmt so ein New Game Plus oder sowas.
Das ist bei so Games ja fast gang und gäbe.
Jetzt kann ich endlich mal meine krasse Cosa-Gaming-Tastatur ausprobieren.
So, Leute, komm, Hard, Difficult, oder?
Menschen, Hard, Difficult.
Jetzt schrägt's.
Hard, Difficult.
Alles weggeaxtet, ja.
Hier geht's nicht lang.
Das Movement gefällt mir schon mal richtig gut.
Ordentlich Speed.
Das ist schon mal richtig gut.
Das Movement gefällt mir schon mal richtig gut.
Ordentlich Speed.
Wir müssen in irgendein anderes Level.
Da? Da.
Und Pötter zerhauen, ganz wichtig.
Ja, man merkt schon, dass das grafisch eher an Quake 2 angelehnt ist,
aber optisch ist es trotzdem sehr hübsch.
Ah, die Texturen sind jetzt nicht so die allerbesten.
Aber ich meine, wozu auch jetzt die Megatexturen machen,
wenn das eh alles klötzchenmäßig...
Oh.
Secret, da wäre ja nie einer draufgekommen.
Quick Save.
Was ist Quick Save?
Quick Save. Gibt's das überhaupt?
Quick Save. F5, F9.
Wait.
Was ist da?
Also wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt,
also auch Technikrahmen oder so,
ich meine, ich habe massig Zeit zu labern.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Game so das Ultra-Hirn braucht.
Wobei es harte für Kult.
Boah.
Schreckt, Alter.
Also wir können über alles Mögliche schwätzen.
Und falls ich es übersehe...
Press Tab to see level stats.
85 Gegner gekillt, time.
Easy.
Oh, was ist das? Da macht es Geräusche.
Thanks, thanks.
Fuck.
Das ist deaf.
Moin.
XR1615.
Speedrun, run.
Tja. Mal gucken.
Aber ich meine, schön schnell...
Schön, schön speedrunnen, also schnell runnen tut man ja.
Moment, hat das Auto-Aim?
Hat das da Auto-Aim gehabt gerade?
Left and right, schön.
Quicksave.
Ihr kennt ja meinen Quicksavetick, ne?
Oh.
Ihr kennt ja meinen Quicksavetick.
Ich quicksave hier laufend.
Vollgas. Also Gameplay technisch...
Komm, die werden jetzt geaxtet.
Oh, die machen aber ganz schön Damage.
Die machen aber ganz schön Damage.
Was ist das?
Was?
What the fuck?
Okay, power up.
Power up ist immer gut.
Okay, die Waffen werden wohl extrem viel stärker mit power up.
Die Axt schnetzelt hier vor sich hin.
Das Ding ist quasi so ein...
sieht aus wie ein Feuerwehrschlauch.
Und das schießt Dinger.
Vor allem, ich frag mich grad, wie du das mit der Axt machen willst.
In Wirklichkeit so...
Das ist so wie die Survival-Channels immer ihr Feuer machen.
Guck dir, ne?
Gibt ja mittlerweile richtig viele Survival-Channels auf YouTube.
Und quasi...
Die Hälfte aus dem Video besteht immer erstmal in der Runde Feuer machen.
Da sitzen sie dann immer da.
So sah das eben grad aus.
Auto run disabled, enabled.
Was ist deine Meinung zum Raspberry Pi 4?
Oh, guck mal da.
Secret.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Der Raspberry Pi 4 ist ein bisschen...
Also wir haben ja...
Moment, wo sind wir denn überhaupt?
Wir haben ja einen Stream dazu gemacht.
Das war der vorletzte oder so.
Also wenn du im Detail wissen willst, was wir uns angeguckt haben, kannst du einfach nochmal den vorletzten Stream oder so ein bisschen durchflicken.
Also ich finde, es ist ein bisschen verschenktes Potenzial.
Hier sind wir hergekommen.
Ich finde, der Raspberry Pi ist ein bisschen verschenktes Potenzial.
Das hat so Sachen wie zwei Bildschirme, die eigentlich kein Mensch braucht.
Ich meine, wer hat sich schon immer gewünscht?
Ja, unbedingt, lass mich bitte...
Lass mich bitte mehr 2, 4K Bildschirme dran machen.
Das wollte eigentlich keiner.
Die CPU-Leistung ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel besser.
Was mich richtig enttäuscht hat, ehrlich gesagt, ist...
Echt?
Kann man da drüberspringen hier?
Kann man hier oben drüberspringen?
Oh, Fliege, Fliegemobs.
Was mich richtig enttäuscht hat beim Raspberry Pi 4 ist, dass der keine Krypto-Extensions in der CPU hat.
Also sprich, die neue ARM-CPU, die der hat, sollte eigentlich Hardware-IS-Verschlüsselung machen können.
Was richtig praktisch gewesen wäre, falls man das Ding als so...
...Pormance NAS verwenden will.
Allerdings ohne Krypto-Extensions ist es doof, da hast du immer nur 30MB pro Sekunde oder sowas, das suckt.
Ah.
Sei denn dich interessiert es nicht, da NAS zu verschlüsseln.
Was natürlich richtig gut ist beim Raspberry, beim neuen, ist natürlich die USB-Geschwindigkeit, Netzwerk-Geschwindigkeit.
Aber das war ja auch die offensichtlichen Sachen, die sich jeder eigentlich denken konnte, wenn er einfach nur mal die Stacks sich...
Oh, woah, woah, oh, oh, was ist das?
Oh, fuck, der macht Damage.
Mensch, lad noch mal neu.
Ah.
Nice, das war alles immer Quick-Save.
Evade, evade.
Erdreckt.
Oh, schön.
Durchgeschnibbelt.
Ach, hier sind wir wieder.
Wieder der Anfang.
Ist da Fahrstuhl?
Hier ist Health.
Okay, dann ist die Seite eigentlich fertig, wenn ich das jetzt richtig gesehen habe.
Ah, wir brauchen beide Schlüssel.
Okay.
Wo sind wir jetzt langgegangen?
Da oder da?
Ich hab's mir nicht gemerkt.
Da, da sind wir grad langgegangen vorhin.
Ja, also es lohnt sich nicht, wenn man...
Also, das Die-Den-Man braucht irgendwas, was von vier Gigabyte RAM braucht.
Lass mich raus.
Okay.
Das Die-Den-Man braucht irgendwas, was von vier Gigabyte RAM... Lass mich raus.
Es sei denn, man hat irgendeine Anwendung, die von vier Gigabyte RAM profitiert, und man kauft sich einen vier Gigabyte Raspberry.
Ich seh den Tut gar nicht.
Wo ist der?
Der down?
Und man braucht ein bisschen mehr CPU-Leistung.
Aber ansonsten gibt's erstmal keinen großartigen Grund, wenn man zufrieden ist mit seinem Raspberry Pi 3, sich da einen neuen zu kaufen.
Ja, der Staff hat ein bisschen Auto-Aim.
Mana hat man mehr als genug, wie es aussieht.
Wobei ich sagen muss, das ist ja das Totale.
Da wird wahrscheinlich noch nicht allzu viel sein.
Schwimmen wir mal.
Gibt bestimmt irgendwelche Secrets.
Nee, gibt's nicht.
Wo hab ich denn meine andere Maus?
Oh, fuck.
Ich hab wieder meine Headset-Verlängerung runtergeschmissen.
Wie krieg ich das immerhin?
Sucked.
Ach so, weil mein Headset mal wieder total verknotet ist.
Wie geht das eigentlich, dass man Headset nicht verknotet, also nicht bewegt, aber sie sich trotzdem verknoten?
Wie funktioniert denn das?
Ist das du mit Zaubern ein bisschen?
So sah das in dem Review-Video aus, deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, das muss man unbedingt mal ausprobieren.
Das sieht nämlich genau aus wie ein Game für mich.
Vielleicht sollte ich nicht mit dem einen...
Ich hab gerade die Hand an der falschen Maus gehabt.
Ich hab gerade die Maus für den anderen PC hier zum Bildchen anzeigen gehabt.
Und das Natur zum Rennen, das hat mir natürlich nicht funktioniert.
Axt.
Bam.
Da geht bestimmt das Level weiter, wenn man das einsammelt.
Oh.
Weg.
Oder auch nicht.
Wo geht's weiter?
Oh, ich seh schon, das wird ein bisschen so verwinkelt erstellt, wo man dann nicht genau weiß, wo man hin muss.
Hier geht's nicht weiter.
Axt.
Bam.
Ach guck mal, da guckt der Fuß raus.
Eckefuß.
Da waren wir schon, da sind wir hergekommen.
Okay, das ist Tutorial Level, die Gegner können noch nix.
Hm, waren wir hier unten schon?
Ich hüpfe mal runter.
Oh fuck, da waren wir schon.
Quick save.
Vor Grafiz, genau, ich hab da irgendwas gehört.
Und das ist ja richtig anstrengend zu spielen.
Für irgendwelche Ultramove mit Noobs ist das aber nix.
Okay, ich bin jetzt runtergehüpft, ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine clevere Idee war.
Doch, ich muss eh hier hin, ich muss eh hier durch.
Ja, sehr schön.
Oh fuck.
Die Wade.
Woin, wo ist mein Schwert?
Schwert?
Drei?
Ach, ich hab kein Mana mehr.
Shit.
Kein Mana mehr für das Schwert.
Das war aber der Mage hier.
Yeah, it's always easy.
Ich glaube, das ist sogar relativ schwer, wenn da noch mehr kommen in späteren Levels,
und die auch so viel Damage machen, dann gibt's aufs Marvel.
Perfect.
Zum Glück hat das Death Auto, ey.
Äh, von wo komm ich?
Von da.
Aber das Gameplay macht richtig Spock.
Ich mach richtig gut Damage.
Aha.
Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich was für Leute, die Games mögen mit schnellem Movement,
und wo man sich auch ein bisschen mit dem Game beschäftigen muss, weil ich könnte mir vorstellen,
werden wir gleich noch sehen, wie das die nächsten Level so sind, dass das was ist,
was richtig schwer wird.
Vor allem auf schwer.
Weil er so beknackt und hab's gleich auf schwer gestellt.
Mein Power-Abzeug verwende ich aber auch so gut wie gar nicht.
Too easy.
Read all inscriptions.
Hab ich das gemacht?
Okay.
Der Soundtrack ist auch cool.
Hier gibt's bestimmt irgendwelche Secrets.
Oder auch nicht.
Hier ist unsichtbare Wand, hier geht's nicht weiter.
Da oben ist so ein Power-Abteil.
Solange das so easy ist, müssen wir noch großartig nach Secrets gucken.
Ähm, läuft das Stream okay?
Ich guck mir das hier nämlich grad im Vorschau an und ich finde, es ist ein bisschen ruckelig.
Aber das könnte an meinem Rechner liegen.
Ich glaub, das liegt an meinem Vorschau-Rechner, dass das ruckelig ist.
Ich glaube, in Wirklichkeit ruckelt da eigentlich gar nichts, oder?
Ruckelt nix.
Oder ruckelt.
Mit 48 FPS soll's eigentlich ziemlich, ziemlich, äh, weich laufen.
Läuft alles.
Axt.
Bam.
Es ist ziemlich bescheuert, die im Nahkampf zu ploppen mit der Axt.
Die machen, au, die machen massive Damage.
Huge Damage.
Besser, wenn man da einen komischen Auto-Aimstab drauf aimt.
Ah, hier gibt's Leben.
Oh, mehr Staff-Mana.
Also vom Gameplay her und Movement macht es echt richtig Bock.
Was hat mich ge-, ach, da ist noch so ein Typ.
Fuck, wo kommen die alle her?
Die waren eben noch nicht da.
Ach, man kann sogar die Angriffe kontern.
Ob der Headshot grad mehr Damage gemacht hat, weil's ein Headshot war?
Ah, ja, ja.
Raucht mal hintereinander, dass man mehr Damage macht.
Au.
Alles down.
Nicht anstrengend zu spielen, weil man ausweichen muss.
Ah, nee, hier geht's nicht auf.
Der ist gest-, ouch.
Der ist gestuck in der Ecke.
Nachdem das das Tutorial-Level ist, scheinen sie wirklich ein bisschen großzügig zu sein, was Mana angeht, was Leben angeht.
Da fliegen Granaten rum.
Fliegen hier Granaten rum, von wo-, ach, von oben.
Kommt mal da hoch.
Ich hab irgendwas ausgelöst, ich weiß nicht genau was.
Erst mal Axt.
Also das ist das einzige, der einzige Spruch-, Overwatch-Spruch, den ich kenn von neuen Helden.
Geht da ein System von gestern? Ja.
Guck mal, was ich zeig's dir.
Bam.
Wie geht's Katz FPS? Die liegt unten grad auf dem Schrank.
Aber das System von gestern geht, wie man hier sieht.
Deine Frage ist drinnen.
Hab ich jetzt beantwortet, kann ich löschen.
Sehr nice.
Deine Frage war nicht hinter euch, ich hab deine Frage gelöscht.
Oben?
Unten?
Also falls ich weiß, nee, nee, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Ich hab gelesen, es gibt glaub ich insgesamt acht, acht solcher unterschiedlichen Welten.
Oder sechs unterschiedliche Welten mit jeweils acht unterschiedlichen Leveln oder sowas.
Das soll auch relativ umfangreich sein.
Und jede Welt hat wohl eigene Gegner, eigene Architektur, eigene Style.
Werden wir sehen.
Give life.
Hast du Urlaub? Nee.
Ich hab leider keinen Urlaub, ich hätte gerne Urlaub.
Urlaub wäre sehr, sehr...
Aber ich hab leider keinen Urlaub, nee.
Und auch keine Ferien oder sowas, ich hab montags einfach nur frei.
Ich hab samstags, sonntags, montags immer frei.
Ok, jetzt machen wir mal unsere Special-Fähigkeit an.
Ganz direkt.
Schreckt.
Wo ist hier noch was? Ich hab noch was gehört.
Easy.
Oh, da ist noch was.
Können nix.
Ach, jetzt hab ich das System erst gecheckt.
Von toten Gegnern sammelt man irgendwie Seelen ein und das lädt dann die Ultimate unten links auf.
Jetzt hab ich das kapiert, ach so.
Machst du am Montag eigentlich immer YouTube-Stuff?
Naja, so war es mal geplant.
Allerdings, nachdem ich ja gerade so viel YouTube mache, mache ich jetzt halt auch nicht so viel YouTube-Stuff am Montag.
Boah, da hat's uns zerrissen.
Also ja, so ist es geplant gewesen, dass ich YouTube-Stuff mache am Montag.
Ah, da kann man super das Schwert nehmen. Hier, die stehen alle in einer Reihe.
Ah, nice.
Secret found. Ich weiß zwar nicht wo, aber ich hab Secret gefoundet.
Mit neuer Waffe. Ok.
Ich weiß nicht wo ich, ich weiß nicht wo ich bin.
Gleicher mal.
Calculated, ja.
Alles calculated.
Grünzeug, Brauma.
Ah, noch mehr Grünzeug, perfekt.
Wie komm ich denn da jetzt wieder hoch?
Hier drüber, hier drüber kann man bestimmt hoch.
Ich blick nicht mehr durch, wo muss ich denn hin?
Au, voll reinspringen.
Beste Idee.
Ach, hier geht's hoch.
Hier bin ich hergekommen gerade, ok.
Ah, hier geht's lang.
Nachdem ich jetzt so sinnlos darunter gechampft bin.
Ja, stellt euch nur alle schön in eine Reihe, dass ich euch wegspammen kann mit dem Schwert.
Au!
Ok, ich glaub hier muss man wirklich ein bisschen mehr musen als...
als wieder asleep ist.
Hext. Hext.
Du musst das nur besser verkaufen, denn du bist der Pro.
Ja, alles, alles kalkuliert.
Vollender Schlüssel.
Ach so.
Oh.
Guck mal, den, den, den hauen wir jetzt um die Ecke rum.
Man kann überhaupt nichts machen.
Ihr entschreckt.
Eckenstells.
Man bräuchte... Gibt es, gibt es so einen Standard-Melee-Angriff?
Das wäre nämlich nice, dass man da einfach reinrennen kann und dann irgendwie dagegen treten oder so.
Ähm. Gibt's, gibt's echt so einen Standard-Melee-Angriff?
Art Increase. Nein, anscheinend nicht.
Ah.
Ok Leute, wo müssen wir hin?
Das haben wir schon. Wo müssen wir hin?
Oh, guck mal da. Power Up.
Ok, also wir haben jetzt den, wir haben jetzt den goldenen Schlüssel.
Das heißt, hier war doch irgendwo... hier war doch irgendwie so ein goldenes Portal.
Nee, da ist der Anfang.
Ich bin verwirrt. Wo geht's lang?
Da rein vielleicht?
Da stehen schon mal Gegner rum. Das ist...
Au. Das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt, wenn da Gegner rumstehen.
Fuck.
Echt.
Packe.
Hier.
Oh.
Ok.
Das ist natürlich ganz praktisch, weil man nicht weiß, wo man hin muss und rumrennt, findet man irgendwelche Secrets.
Boah.
Direkt. Tyrannosaurus schreckt.
Also anscheinend gibt's sieben Waffen, wenn man dem Menü glaubt.
Robbe. Genau, die Robbe macht uns...
Die Aufzüge spacken noch ein bisschen rum.
Leben. Leben kann man nicht genug haben. Mana haben wir genug.
Ach, hier sind wir jetzt.
Das ist ganz am Anfang.
Wir haben jetzt den goldenen Schlüssel. Wo müssen wir lang?
Immer da lang, wo Gegner sind. Das kann nie schaden.
Direkt.
Hier kommen wir her. Sind hier oben.
Das ist verwirrend.
Hier haben wir den Schlüssel gefunden. Das kann jetzt nicht allzu weit sein.
Ich glaube, ich bin zu dumm für solche Spiele.
Einfach hier unten lang?
The fuck, wo muss ich hin?
So ging's wie im ersten Half-Life auch immer. Da hast du an manchen Stellen gedacht...
Geht's lang?
Hallo? Abukizi?
Okay, es ist bestimmt total simpel, wo ich lang muss.
Ha! Hier!
Ja, das war ein guter Zeitpunkt, mal hier Ultimate zu ziehen.
Schön rausgesprayt.
Der ist verpackt.
Zack, und neue Ultimate.
Unsere komischen Mörserdudes.
Noch mehr Ultimate spammen.
Schnell, bevor unsere Ultimate vorbei ist, muss ich die Typen auch noch raunen, da drüben.
Eckgesprayt.
Oh, Achievement. Wie guckt man bei GOG? Achso, Extend Soulmode for 30 seconds.
Ich wollte grad sagen, wie guckt man bei GOG, was für ein Achievement was ist, aber anscheinend so.
Toll, wieder so ein Viech, der wird weggeaxtet.
Weggeaxtet, jawoll.
Ach, hier geht's.
Ach, hier sind wir! Das ist da, wo wir aus Versehen reingetaucht sind.
Easy.
Also aktuell ist Harddifficult noch nicht so hart.
Aber ich glaube, das wird noch schwieriger.
Ach guck mal, die Axt zieht die Gegner ran, wenn man rückwärts läuft.
Was ich ja an so Games cool finde, ist, dass die einem nicht jeden Scheiß erklären.
Nicht erstmal 50 Tutorial-Videos angucken muss oder irgendwelche Tutorial-Missionen zwischendurch machen muss.
Sondern einfach gucken, wenn man rückwärts läuft.
Jetzt hat's nicht funktioniert.
Er zockt fast. Ja, ich hab ein Video gesehen, so ein Video-Review zu dem Game.
Hab ich mir gedacht, das muss ich ausprobieren. Sieht übelst nice aus.
Ich, komm her.
Next, please.
Genau, für mich ist Hard E Eats.
Die Sache, wenn man was gut kann, ist alles Eats.
Aber ich glaube, das wird noch richtig schwierig.
Zumindest Games in dieser Art, wie früher Hexen oder Quake 2, die waren auch nicht ohne.
Hexen 2 hab ich nie durchgespielt, war ich zu dumm für.
Hab ich nie gecheckt, wo ich lang muss. Kennt das noch jemand?
Hexen 2, das war übelst verwirrend.
Da fängst du in so einer Mittelalterstadt an und sollst Leute bashen und du weißt nicht, wo du lang musst.
Das Game hat ja auch null geholfen.
Also das war ganz beschissen.
Also es waren nicht alle Spiele gut damals, nur weil sie alt sind.
Oh, die wollen geaxet werden.
Jetzt, Moment, man muss gerade rückwärts laufen, dann zieht die Axt die Gegner an und One-Hitted sie.
Das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Komm, rückwärts, komm her.
Ich glaube, das ist keine so gute Idee, wenn ich das probier.
Komm her.
So genau hab ich noch nicht gecheckt, wie das mit der Axt funktioniert.
Sprayen wir die lieber so weg von Range.
Hier, da brauchen wir unser Auto-Aim.
Was ich auch noch nicht gecheckt hab, ist, ob Headshots extra Damage machen.
Aber eigentlich ist das bei vielen Games damals so gewesen, dass Headshots extra Damage waren.
Das heißt, ich könnte mir vorstellen, vielleicht auch so ist.
Die zersplattern schön, das gefällt mir.
Splash.
Eif kann man nie genug haben.
Wir haben volles, nee, der grünes Mana ist fast voll.
Au.
Warum sind so Mörsertudes wieder?
Da steht einer, den hat die AI kaputt gemacht.
Ich hab doch hier noch so eine andere Waffe gekriegt gerade.
Die kann man bestimmt auch schön über Range verwenden.
Kann man die Dinger kaputt machen?
Die ist gesplattert.
Okay, das heben wir nicht auf, wir haben schon Power-Up.
Wir hatten doch noch eine Waffe.
Dieses Ding haben wir noch.
Die werden jetzt geregt damit.
Da machen sie nichts.
Oh nee, fuck, ich bin runtergefallen.
Aber ich glaube, ich muss eh runter.
Ich glaube, ich muss eh runter.
Also Moving und Gameplay machen übelst Bock.
Auch, dass man schneller wird, wenn man springt, ist sehr nice.
Spring hoch, spring hoch.
Okay, wo geht's lang?
Da, da, da, da.
Nee, falscher Knopf.
Mana, Mana.
Da ist noch Mana.
Staff.
Da muss man bestimmt rüberjumpen, jawoll.
Die Musik geht voll ab im Hintergrund, obwohl überhaupt nichts passiert.
Face.
Wenn man das noch oft genug sagt, dann passiert es irgendwann auch.
Hier waren wir schon auf der anderen Seite.
200 Health-Secret, nicht, dass wir es gebraucht hätten.
Mörser, Dude.
Axt.
Achtung, wir werden weggeaxtet jetzt.
Alles weggeaxtet.
Okay, Heart ist doch nicht so hart.
Wenn ich Max Leben und Max Mana habe auf Heart, dann stimmt ja was nicht.
Brauchen wir noch Hyper Heart.
Das Game hat bestimmt einen New Game Plus Modus.
Wo kommt man her?
Da.
So Games haben immer einen New Game Plus Modus.
Was skulpturst du eigentlich, Axt?
Für euer RPG da noch?
Komm raus, komm raus.
Komm raus.
Was passiert, wenn man da runterspringt?
Ich gehe mal davon aus, man stirbt.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ja, man stirbt.
Ja, ich stehe immer im Discord.
Ich falle in dem Game gerne runter und finde Secrets, kann das sein?
Was ist das hier?
Morgenstern.
Und?
Ach, hier sind wir wieder.
Was macht man?
Ist das Nahkampfwaffe?
Nee, das ist Fernkampfwaffe.
Die Waffe ist nice.
Die gefällt mir.
Die Waffe gefällt mir.
Guck mal, bam, zurück.
Das gefällt mir.
Vor allem, wie sie so gegen die Wand tackert.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an das Ding in Vierer und die Leute auch gegen die Wand.
Alter, wie sie zerreißt.
Das frisst auch viel mehr Mana als das Schwert.
Du spammst mal dein System.
Warum willst du mal ein System spammen?
Ach, mit Fragen oder so?
Ja, mach, mach.
Lichteffekte sind sehr hübsch.
Oh, die Waffe ist ja mega nice.
Man frisst ordentlich Mana, aber das macht nicht Bock.
Guck mal hier, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Deswegen ist es ein ordentliches Secret, wenn man da sowas findet.
Okay, ich glaube, wir haben alles gesammelt.
Hier gibt es noch gutes Mana.
Da ist noch was.
Quick Save.
Au.
Ich müsste noch zielen können.
Oh, die zerfetzt ja.
Das gefällt mir.
Okay, da bin ich so blöd zum Treffen.
Da brauch ich mein Auto-Aim-Step.
Machst du mal ein Fan-Treffen?
Ich hab's jetzt nicht vor.
Außerdem guckt mich doch eh keiner mehr.
So 2011 wäre das was anderes gewesen.
Da wären aber viele gekommen.
Aber aktuell...
Was heißt, guckt keiner mehr?
Ich müsste erst mal Videos machen, dass überhaupt jemand gucken könnte, ne?
Bull.
Merch, ne.
Wobei, ich hab's mir ja schon mal überlegt.
Das haben damals auch viele gesagt.
Gar nicht so lange her, zwei Jahre.
Dass die tatsächlich das gerne hätten.
Hat mich echt gewundert.
Hab ich gar nicht gedacht.
Komm her.
Weggeaxtet.
Oh.
Ich bin zurück.
Auto-Aim-Step.
Der Auto-Aim-Step ist gegen Fliegendinger sehr praktisch.
Äh.
Hallo?
Da gibt's viel Leben, das ist gut.
Der Auto-Aim-Step ist übelst easy mode.
Seht ihr, wie das Ding um die Ecke schießen kann?
Jetzt gibt's auch viel Leben.
Hier stirbt man bestimmt, weil er in die Mitte reinhüpft.
Noch nicht mal da.
Achtung, Axt.
Arm.
Eckt.
Aber das, finde ich, ist bis jetzt die beste Waffe.
Das fetzt die Gegner so richtig schön.
Hier, guck.
Bam.
Alter.
Haha, das ist nice.
Die Waffe war übelst bock.
Da dreist die Gegner so schön.
Übelst hohe Sensitivity eingestellt.
Treffe im Endeffekt da gar nichts.
Also die Fall ist das eingestellt.
Äh.
Geht's denn hier lang?
Schlüssel, jawoll.
Holen wir das Fleisch.
Au.
Lass uns mal kurz hier auf der anderen Seite gucken.
Gibt's noch Life?
Haben wir alle?
Wir haben eigentlich alle schon.
Hier waren wir schon.
Wo wohnst du?
In Frankfurt.
MonkaS.
Alter.
Ist ja gut.
Ich glaub ohne die Waffe wär das schwieriger gewesen.
Gibt's eine Frau wo bloß?
Nee.
Gibt keine Frau wo bloß.
Auch kein Frau-FPS.
Und auch kein Grill-FPS.
Doch, ein Grill-FPS gibt's.
Ein Hockengrill.
Next.
Wir können jetzt gleich mal gucken, ob tatsächlich das funktioniert hier mit.
Zack.
Ja, das tun ist wirklich praktisch.
Die Emotes sind drinne.
Sehr cool.
Sehr nice.
Haben wir beantwortet, haben wir beantwortet.
Haben wir beantwortet.
Pepega-Board, ja.
Das ist, weil ich immer vergesse Sachen zu beantworten.
Das andere Zeug ist noch von gestern, das können wir eigentlich immer löschen.
Der Katz geht's gut.
Emotes, Arpy, du mit Zaubern, ja.
Hab ich alles beantwortet.
Weiter.
Also Gameplay-technisch macht das wirklich Spaß.
Oh, das sieht nach Endgegner aus.
Ich wusste es.
So ein Raum mit irgendwie nichts drin, das sieht immer nach Endgegner aus.
Okay, der kann nix.
Zack, der kann nix.
Kann er nix.
Au, okay, der kann, au.
Okay, da, okay, da muss man aufpassen.
Aber der ist gleich down.
Easy as a fuck.
Leute, ich lad noch mal neu.
Ich will mal, ich will mal gucken, wie schnell der down ist, wenn ich den mit Ulti, wenn
ich, wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich den mit Ulti-Mate angreife.
Achtung.
Kein Reg.
Oh, noch mal neu.
Das war easy, das war mega easy.
Okay, jetzt probierst du mal Ulti-Mate mit dem, mit dem Morgenstern hier.
Okay, wenn alle Endgegner so sind.
Okay, jetzt kann man nämlich mal die Ulti-Mates ausprobieren.
Das ist ja lustig.
Okay, Endgegner gegen Ulti-Mate sind ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich schlecht.
Guck mal, ich kann das auch.
Das ist der Endgegner aus.
Halber Mixer, ja.
Die Axt ist geil im Ulti-Mate-Modus.
So viel Spaß an sinnlosem rumgeballert.
Oh, da hatte ich ja schon lang, da wäre er.
Oh, das ist so Quake-Lightning-Gun.
Die macht aber nicht so viel Damage.
Aber Damage genug.
Also merke, bei Endgegnern, immer diesen komischen Spezial-Modus da haben.
Das haben wir noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ulti-Mate.
Alter!
Du siehst ja gar nichts mehr.
Mit dem Teil.
So, und jetzt probieren wir es nochmal ohne Ulti-Mate.
Wobei, wir hatten ja eben schon mal gekillt ohne Ulti-Mate.
War ja auch easy as fuck.
Ja, das ist ja auch noch das Tutorial-Level.
Wahrscheinlich wird es auch noch ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber wir haben es geschafft.
200% Leben.
Haben wir nicht gebraucht.
So, äh...
Schafft.
Tutorial-Level durch.
Oh, ich habe das Secret nicht gefunden.
Gibt Schlimmeres. Wir haben es trotzdem easy geschafft.
Das war...
Was ist das? Das ist A-Mid-Evil.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Quake.
Ist aber, kam erst vor einer Woche oder so raus.
Das Sound, wenn er die Treppe hochspringt.
Hier kann man jetzt...
Ah, Difficult Selection.
Ok, ähm...
Wo sind wir gerade gewesen? Hier.
Da dürfen wir nicht lang.
Da müssen wir erst zwei andere welten.
Hier waren wir gerade.
Wo müssen wir jetzt hin? Was ist das?
Next. Next Level.
To Main of the Sentinels.
Ich finde es schön, dass sie das so farbenfroh gemacht haben in diesem Game.
Passt farblich ganz gut, oder?
Schwert. Schwert. Bevor die Gegner kommen.
Alter, was ist das?
Was ist das für ein Viech?
Au!
Ok.
Das trifft man nicht richtig.
Direkt.
Alles aufgesammelt.
Die machen jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr Damage als im Tutorial Level.
Programmierst du heute noch?
Es könnte sein, dass wir nachher noch ein bisschen weitermachen.
Ich bin ja schon ziemlich früh.
Ich habe mir jetzt so viel Video angeguckt, aber ich dachte, das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Geht es hier weiter? Hier geht es gar nicht weiter.
Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, wenn man hier noch mal lang muss, dann erwachen die Dinger.
Das machen Games doch irgendwie gerne so, oder?
Das sind irgendwelche Statuen rumstehen, weil es hält da schon ganz am Anfang so.
Du läufst irgendwann noch mal durch und auf einmal sind die Dinger dann am Leben und awnen dich.
Alter, die machen, die machen Damage.
Master Chief.
Was macht eigentlich Halo 6?
Hatten die was auf der E3 gezeigt?
Alter, die machen ja übelst Damage, die Viecher.
Hatten die eigentlich was gezeigt?
Ach, ich habe meinen Stab noch nicht.
Deswegen klappt das die ganze Zeit nicht.
Ja, Gegner, die Damage machen, was soll das da?
Die haben Auto-Aim-Angriffe.
Das ist unfair.
Richtig schlimm.
Das Pro-Aim ist wieder am Start.
Was?
Was mein...
Warum kriegt man...
Alter, warum kriegt man Damage, wenn man von hinten an den Block dran läuft?
Das ist ja total bescheuert.
Jetzt muss ich doch mal ausprobieren, ist das echt so?
Was?
Warum?
Warum kriegt man Damage, wenn man an den Block hinten läuft?
Habe ich voll viel Leben verloren, aber da oben war noch was.
Das gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Was ist das?
Die Gegner machen tatsächlich schon ein bisschen mehr Damage als die vorher.
Richtiges Pepegas.
Ich glaube, die muss man headshotten.
Wenn ich headshotte, kommt so ein rotes Ding.
Guck, jetzt habe ich den nicht headshotten.
Das ist ein komisches grünes Ding.
Ein rotes Ding.
Oh, der Stab.
Der Stab ist richtig gut gegen die Fliegedinger, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Auto-Aim, Auto-Aim im Rückwärtsgang.
Ich kann ja springen.
Wie alt ich bin?
Nächsten Monat bin ich 35.
Wo ist das Viech da?
Also richtig alter Sack.
Old AF bin ich.
Hab ich ja jetzt getroffen.
Oh, Viech.
Ihh, Klötzchen-Dinger.
Jump-and-Run-Einlagen, habe ich früher übelst gehasst in Games.
Ich glaube, so wie ich das gemacht habe, ist es nicht gedacht.
Ich glaube, das ist so nicht gedacht, wie ich da gerade durchgelackt bin.
Oh.
Splatter.
Ich will wieder hochfahren.
Hochfahren, da oben war noch eine Waffe.
War noch eine extra Waffe, jawoll.
Kann man immer gebrauchen.
Und leben.
Nice.
Wo hat es gekrunzt?
Wisst ihr, was mich wundert?
Dass die nicht in Neuestu QQ schon längst angekündigt haben.
Ich meine, Forever war jetzt nicht so toll.
Aber auch nicht so scheiße, wie es viele gemacht haben.
Aber es war immer nur eine recht bekannte Marke.
Ich glaube, Gearbox hatte die Rechte.
Ich wundere mich, dass sie nicht schon wieder was Neues angekündigt haben.
Äh, wo geht es lang?
Hier?
Ah, beste Waffe.
Die Waffe ist echt nice.
Okay, bin ich jetzt überhaupt richtig gelaufen?
Ich habe gelesen, dass die Welten komplett unterschiedlich sind.
Das ist so nice, wie es sie zerfetzt.
Nein, warum habe ich das aufgesammelt?
Total wasted, ich habe doch schon eine Ultimate am Start.
Gegen die Waffe sind die Dinger machtlos.
Guck mal, wie die geregt werden.
Eigentlich lohnt es sich, Seelen aufzusammeln.
Auch überhaupt nicht, solange ich noch meine Ultimate am Start habe.
Easy.
Und hier waren wir doch schon.
Hier waren wir schon.
Das Leveldesign verwirrt mich.
Ich glaube, das ist Absicht.
Auto entstarb.
Beste.
Ah, gegen die Dinger war glaube ich die Axt gut.
Nein, das hat jetzt einfach mal fast 100 Leben gekostet.
Dann nehmen wir unseren...
Was ist das?
Das ist gar kein Morgenstern.
Das ist ein komisches Splitterwerf-Ding.
Aber es regt einfach alles.
Es war richtig hardcore.
Bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Also Hard-Difficult ist aktuell nicht sonderlich hart.
Wenn man sich überlegt.
Keine Ahnung von dem Game.
Piss dich, Alter.
Ach, das ist der Fahrstuhl.
Ganzen Mist mal einsammeln.
Die Dinger wachen jetzt doch 100% auf, oder?
Kann ich auch richtig vorstellen.
Läuft es hier durch und...
Ja.
Nee.
Äh.
Nice.
Oh, Leute.
Easy.
Weggeklitscht.
Vielleicht habe ich das Level jetzt aber auch kaputt gemacht.
Ich lade mal neu.
Vielleicht habe ich das Level kaputt gemacht.
Ich gucke mal, ob die Wand von alleine weggeht, wenn ich die Gegner kille.
Ach ja, easy.
Das war dann...
Das ist ja langweilig.
Dann hat mir das rumgeklitscht und ja gar nichts gebracht.
Speedrun-Stats.
Direkto.
Die haben ordentlich Damage gefressen gerade.
Bisschen komisch gemacht, dass man verlängert seine Zeit von dieser Spezialfähigkeit, wenn
man Seelen einsammelt.
Allerdings ist die lang genug, um einen Fight zu gewinnen.
Und dann muss man kurz warten, dass sie nicht addiert, sondern wieder neu auflädt.
Das ist komisch.
Hätte ich auch gleich weiter rennen können.
Amethyst, recht, das ist Exit vom Level.
Fortress.
Eve-Mana.
Warte mal.
Wie kommt man hier gescheit rein?
Beste.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Ultimag am Start.
So muss es sein.
Orangenschneides Mana ist relativ selten.
Achtung, die werden jetzt wieder gegen die Wand geschreckt.
Bam.
Nein.
Au.
In your face.
Die Waffe ist echt nice.
Das macht richtig Spock.
Unverplatziert.
Ich brauch Leben, die Dinger machen zu viel Damage.
Au.
Eins Leben.
Ich brauch Leben.
Wo sind Leben?
Oh, da schießt irgendwas auf mich.
Ah, Leben.
Nice.
Ein bisschen mehr Leben wäre auch okay.
Die machen echt ordentlich Damage jetzt.
Oh, hier gibt es schön viel Leben.
Wir flieben.
Ich glaub, das ist taktisch nicht so geschickt, was ich da mache.
Ich muss die Einzel, Einzel schrecken.
Und hinter mir.
Warum ist da auf einmal hinter mir was?
Die waren doch eh noch nicht da.
Fuck.
Okay, jetzt wird es doch relativ schwierig.
Guck mal, hinter mir ist nichts.
Jetzt geh ich hoch.
Aha.
Da wird einfach gespawnt.
Einfach so gespawnt.
Alter.
Okay.
Wie machen wir das jetzt?
Wir lassen die jetzt spawnen und rennen runter.
Und starben den um.
Ups.
Umgestabt.
Auch umgestabt.
Ah, schön starbauto geaimt.
Fünf Leben, ist das euer Ernst?
Ja.
Ich hab die gleiche an.
Easy.
Jawoll.
Jetzt haben wir's.
Teleportieren die jetzt auf einmal?
Ja, jetzt haben wir's.
Down.
Okay, ist doch jetzt relativ schwierig gerade.
Was darf?
Diese kleinen Mana-Dinger sind, so wie ich das gesagt hab, die einzigen, die sogar noch
über 100, äh, nicht Mana, äh, die kleinen Leben-Dinger sind die einzigen, mit denen
man über 100 Prozent Leben kriegen kann.
Oder halt, oder halt das große Auflade-Ding, das gibt's ja auch noch.
Aber gameplay-technisch macht das wirklich Spaß.
Oh, oh, oh.
Umgestabt.
Die müssen im Rückwärtsgang auto-aimt werden.
Auto-aim.
Easy.
Kennen sie sich immer mit Platform, IO und Arduino aus?
Ja, das haben wir doch vor zwei Streams gemacht, oder vor drei Streams haben wir doch Arduino-Platform-IO
gebastelt.
Was willst du denn wissen?
Easy as a fuck.
Geht's hier weiter?
Hallo.
Und weg.
Weg ist plädert.
Auf!
Da haben sie sich angestellt von der Seite.
Weg, weg, weg, weg, schreckt, Tyrannosaurus schreckt, hier wreckt.
Ich höre gar nichts hier.
Über mir stellst du irgendwas.
Diese Auto-aim-Kugeln sind wirklich nervig.
Ich hab auch Auto-aim-Kugeln.
Jawoll.
Ah, jetzt hab ich die Waffe kapiert.
Man elektroschockt ein und dann splädert der und schockt den anderen mit.
Ach so.
Brauchst du also, der Nicky schreibt, ich bräuchte ein bisschen Hilfe, da ich ein Byte mit einem
String vergleichen möchte und mir wird halt nur gesagt, geht nicht.
Naja, wenn du ein Byte und ein String vergleichen willst, musst du dich als erstes mal überlegen,
was möchtest du denn genau vergleichen?
Das Byte als Zahl, die Bitreihenfolge, was willst du miteinander vergleichen?
Ich mein, dass man String und Byte nicht direkt vergleichen kann, ist ja irgendwo naheliegend,
ne?
Was willst du denn genau miteinander vergleichen?
Das Byte quasi als Int, das Byte als Bit-Folge, das Spielmonter, ja.
Da ist Colt auch schon, bist schon wieder, bist schon daheim.
Switch.
Kann man hier rüberjumpen?
Boah, boah, nice.
Aber hier gibt's nix.
Oh da, guck mal da.
Sieg, Siegret, Siegret.
Die werden jetzt mit Spezialfähigkeit geohnt.
Wobei, für einen Gegner brauch ich keine Spezialfähigkeit, soweit er auch irgendwie
gestuckt ist.
Aber hier sollten noch mehr Gegner kommen.
Sind die gerade verbugt, die Gegner?
Die machen nix.
Lol, die waren nix.
Ach, ich bin unsichtbar, guck mal unten links, ich bin unsichtbar.
Ich hab irgendwie gerade mein, mein Fenster zugemacht auf der anderen Seite.
Das war so ein unsichtbar Power-Up.
Jetzt, jetzt spawnen sie alle.
Moment, warum stirbt das nicht?
Weil ich nicht treffe.
Ich denk mal, das wird die Welt, das wir gleich geschafft haben.
Weil auch wenn es abwächst und es reich ist, ist es so toll, sieht das jetzt nicht aus.
Die fallen für übelst verwirrend aus.
Hallo.
In your face, in your face, in your face.
Weiter.
Easy.
Boah, weggesplattert.
Ich hab ne Idee, wir auto-aimen die wieder weg.
Hehe.
Diese Gegner sind, kacknubs, ey.
Hören nicht durchs Loch.
Kennst du dich mit MQTT aus, ja?
Naja, gut, also, in Stream mit nem Bein zu vergleichen geht ja erstmal nicht.
Du musst ja wissen, als was du das, was du davon vergleichen willst.
Sonst ergibt es ja auch logisch gesehen keinen Sinn.
Das ist so ein bisschen, wie wenn du sagst, ich will den Int unten im Swing vergleichen.
Das ist ja auch, was willst du, willst du quasi so wie es Dezimal ist?
Willst du es als Bytes? Willst du es als Bitfall? Also, als was willst du es vergleichen?
Oh nice.
Da fährt was hoch und runter.
Da wo das hoch und runter fährt, müssen wir bestimmt mit...
Oh fuck, wir sind grad in 30 Gegner gesprungen.
Jetzt wird geschnitzelt, geschnetzelt.
Aber meinetwegen auch geschnitzelt.
Da müssen wir lang.
Bisschen Leben wär nicht schlecht.
Da oben sind noch Leben.
Sonst gibt es hier keine Leben mehr.
Ach, wir werden es, wir werden es schon nicht verraten.
Da, doch, dahinter ist er mal live.
Wie? Wie ich? Wie ich?
Also wenn du willst, Nicky, können wir gleich noch eine Runde Arduino Platform IO machen.
Du musst nur ein bisschen genauer beschreiben, was das Problem ist.
Wir haben genug Boards da.
Schlecht detaillierte Augen vor allem.
Pixel-liche Augen.
Moment, hier waren wir doch gerade.
Ach, hier geht es lang.
Oh, dass ihr jetzt wieder Zeit für unsere Ultimate-Gespräche.
Easy.
Alles weg.
Alles weg, geflammen werfert.
Irgendwas läuft hier noch, ich hör noch was.
Bisschen Leben noch.
Komm, Auto-Aim, die geht mal weg.
Jawoll.
Nice.
Da geht es lang, eindeutig.
Wenn jetzt hier schon die Brücke gespawnt ist.
Halls of Doom.
Ich denk mal, das letzte Level hier.
Ist das ein Fantasy-Doom? Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Ich wusste auch nicht, dass es das gibt.
Ich hab aber in so ein Review-Video geguckt und festgestellt, das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Jawoll, 200% Leben, nice.
So, jetzt können wir sie weg, Auto-Aim.
Nee, wir Auto-Engine nicht weg, wir schnacken uns das Ding und sprayen sie weg.
Alles weggesprayt.
Oh, mein Granatwerfer.
Aber sehe ich das richtig? Ist das gar kein Granatenwerfer, sind das Planeten oder sowas?
Sieht aus wie ein Planet. Der Planetenwerfer, sorry, nicht der Granatwerfer.
Ich weiß nicht, wo es lang geht. Hier.
Das Ziel, ein Sammeln, dass wir wieder Ultimate kriegen.
Hier geht es linkswo lang, da kommen wir her.
Dann gehen wir da unten lang.
Au, au, weg.
Warum dürft ihr um die Ecke schießen? Das darf nur ich. Nur ich darf um die Ecke schießen.
Wie sie klitscht. Wie sie weggeklitscht.
Kommt man hier um die Ecke? Oh, das könnte klappen, oder?
Oder auch nicht.
Das Game gibt es nächstes Jahr für die Switch, das ist doch jetzt erst rausgekommen.
Warum kriegt die Switch immer die Releases so ewig spät?
Eh, funktioniert nicht. Oder ich bin einfach nur zu Movement Noob in dem Game, dass ich das hinkriege.
Ja, es würde auch gut zur Switch passen.
Das kann man wunderbar mal so ein, zwei Level mobil spielen.
Nee, hier geht es nicht lang.
Splattert. Fliegen Augen lang.
Wo geht es hier lang?
Au.
Okay, also was schreibt der Nicky? Eine Schleife?
Äh. Warum? Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Du nimmst ein Charakter von deinem Payload, weißt dem Ping zu und dann? Wozu? Verstehe ich nicht. Also warum?
Und danach gibst du es aus. Du kannst doch einfach auch direkt Payload, also ePayload ausgeben.
Remake aus den 19. Es sieht ein bisschen so aus, ja. Wobei man sagen muss, die Effekte und so sind deutlich, deutlich besser.
Was denn das? Oh, OP Waffe.
Das kriegen wir schön dahin. Leute, das kriegen wir schön dahin.
Wir rennen da jetzt hin, schnappen uns die Waffe. Und wenn alles gespawnt ist, schießen wir die dahin. Aber erst wenn alles gespawnt ist. Jetzt so.
Wow. Warum bin ich jetzt 5 Meter rumgeflogen?
Ich muss noch was ausprobieren. Ich muss die Waffe nochmal mit Ultimate ausprobieren. Was die Waffe mit Ultimate macht.
Nice. So eine Art schwarzes Loch.
Ich monkaS. MonkaX war das schon. So, da lang oder da lang? Nee, da lang kommen wir her.
So, kurz die Klimaanlage ausmachen. Es wird zu kühl.
Es wird gar nicht mehr so kalt. Ja, genau, Nicky.
Das merke ich mir. Also Nicky, wenn du willst, wir können, wenn ich hier fertig bin, können wir danach noch eine Runde Arduino-Plattform-IO basteln.
Von der Idee her, würde ich gucken, also ich war aus dem Kopf, weiß ich es auch nicht. Du willst ja den kompletten...
No, no. Playing for the first time. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen, Nicky? Also so wie ich das sehe, du willst ja vergleichen...
Also die Beins, die in Payload drin stehen, willst du vergleichen mit was? Mit irgendeinem String in einer anderen Variable oder was?
What the fuck, was ist das?
Dann würde ich mal hier nachgucken. Guck mal, ob du hier irgendwie deinen Bites direkt ins String kopieren kannst oder ob das String, der hat wahrscheinlich sogar irgendeinen Constructor, der direkt einen Character-Bite-Array nimmt.
Du kannst garantiert einen Character-Bite-Array nehmen und zu einem String umwandeln lassen. 100% wenn man den richtigen Constructor findet.
Und wenn der normale String nicht geht, also wenn der Arduino-String nicht geht, dann nehm den Standard-String von C++. Da geht es auf jeden Fall mit.
Nice. Schlüssel. Moment. Auto-Aim. Wie kriegen wir den am besten weg hier mit dem Granatwerfer?
Die zerfetzt schön.
Ja, Niki, das können wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Also ich könnte wetten, dass das String schon einen Constructor hat, der einen Bite-Array nimmt. Wäre ja auch irgendwie blöd, wenn ich... Weiß nicht so genau, wo es lang geht.
Ach, da sind wir jetzt. Metro 2033. Ist 2033 der letzte, der rausgekommen ist?
Wir machen mal einen kleinen Einschub kurz. Was ich meine ist folgendes.
Der erste, ja den ersten fand ich ganz cool. Also Niki, was ich meine ist folgendes. Wenn du jetzt einen Bite-Array hast, ich kann es jetzt nicht ausführen auf... Nerv jetzt nicht rum. Ich kann es jetzt nicht ausführen hier auf... Ich hab jetzt kein Board dran. Aber wenn du irgendwie einen Bite-Array hast, wenn ich jetzt... Geh weg.
Ah, du hast ja einen Bite-Array. Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie die richtige Syntax in C ist. So, ne?
Ne, C++, Moment, wir sind in C++. Ja, so, ne? Wie war Bite-Array Syntax in C++ immer noch? In C sharp ist es so... Ich glaub, Bite, so, ne?
Ne, doch. Irgendwie so. Ja. Es gibt bestimmt... Es gibt bestimmt hier einen Constructor, den du verwenden kannst mit... Mit einem Bite-Array drinne.
Oder auch nicht. Aber der C++ String hat sowas garantiert.
Ja. Moment. Das ist wahrscheinlich jubelst easy. Oh. Ihh. Wo waren die denn da?
Ach so, man muss das... Man muss das casten, ne? Ja, so. Ha. So, und jetzt hast du den String. Jetzt hast du den String aus deinem Payload.
Oder? Muss man nicht noch angeben... Muss man nicht noch angeben, wie lang... Wie lang das Ganze ist? Probier's mal so. Muss man... Ja, Nullterminator ist es nämlich nicht.
Man muss mit dem... Ich dachte, man muss dem dann noch ne... Ach so. Ja, passt. Genau, weil du musst dem sagen, wie lang das Ganze noch ist. Sonst funktioniert das nämlich nicht.
Ich check die Autos Autocompletion hier ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht. Aber das klingt sinnvoll. Probier's mal so. Wie lang dein Payload ist, weißt du ja. Ja, geht doch.
Genau. Size N. Genau so. So müsste das funktionieren. Dann hast du den C++ Standard String. Kann ich als Länge eine Variable... Klar, wenn du eine Variable hast, wo die Länge drin steht.
Au. Da steht ein Viech dahinter. Wo kommt das her und warum? Warum ist da ein Viech auf einmal? Ich hab jetzt voll das Level Layout vergessen. Wo geht's hier lang?
Und wo geht's da... Ah, hier ging's hoch, ne? Aber hier waren wir doch gerade schon. Ach ne, wir waren hier nicht. Wir sind runtergefallen, weil ich ein Kacknoob bin, der runterfällt.
Da hängt's an der Wand. Ah, hier geht's jetzt lang. Da waren wir noch nicht, oder? Doch, hier waren wir vorher auch schon drinnen. Oben noch nicht.
Und was für Reckenfisch. Ah. Hinten geht's lang, hä? Moment, die Steine waren vorhin hier noch nicht oben.
Pissed euch. Okay, ihr wollt weg auto-aimed werden, ich seh's schon. Easy as fuck. Der Auto... Was die richtig gut hingekriegt haben, ist, dass alle Waffen halbwegs relevant sind.
Nicht so, wie du es früher teilweise hast. Du hast irgendwie Pistole, Submachine Gun, Assault Rifle und sobald du das letzte hast, brauchst du nicht mehr. Die Pistole in Half-Life war z.B. übelst useless.
Ähm, die machen ganz schön Damage. Giff, Giff Leben. Oh. Warum, das ist, das ist, das ist grad direkt durch den Gegner durchgeflogen, oder? Hab ich mich da jetzt verguckt.
Perfection.
Doch nicht so perfekt, weil das Tor ist noch zu. Ach hier. Kommt das doch runter?
Der Auto-aim-Stab ist eine gute Default-Waffe.
Moment, die müssen auto-aimed werden. Oder? Nee, die müssen nicht auto-aimed werden. Die müssen, die müssen weg-OP'd werden.
Das ist nicht alles gestorben. Die werden jetzt weg, weggaunt hier mit dem Ding.
Achtung Leute. Hochfahren und jetzt spawnen die Gegner. Wo spawnen die Gegner?
So geil, man mag's, wie das zu zocken ist. Ich würd' viel gerne viel mehr spielen, wenn's ordentliche Games gäbe.
Gibt's hier noch ein bisschen Leben. Ich kann's übrigens bis jetzt nur empfehlen. Also Gameplay-Technik macht das wirklich Bock. Also Massive. Huge.
Huge Bock.
Niki, das sieht ganz gut aus. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Du, das geht so nicht. Du musst das so machen. Schreib mal, Niki schreib da mal Auto davor. Oder schreib, wenn du's explizit angeben willst, schreib das hier davor.
Weil so versuchst du nämlich den Arduino-String, den C++-String zuzuweisen. Das kann nicht funktionieren.
Ich würd's mit Auto machen, so. Da hast du dann hast du einen C++-String. Pick's und fertig und kannst den mit anderen Strings vergleichen.
Battlefield 3, Bad Company 2, PC. Wir könnten mal wieder Bad Company 2 spielen. Da hätt' ich übertrieben Bock drauf. Und ich werd' auf jeden Fall, also sollten sie wirklich Bad Company, was ist denn hier los? Sollten sie wirklich, wo geht's lang?
Oh fuck. Sollten sie wirklich Bad Company 3 ankündigen, werd' ich Bad Company 2 nochmal übelst in Crying starten, so ein paar Monate bevor es rausgeht. Bevor es rauskommt.
Nur um dann festzustellen, dass es sacken wird. Ich glaube, die können's einfach nicht mehr. Ah, Level-Ende. Aber vorher wird der erst noch geackstet. Mit Auto geht's, dank. Ja, nice. Niki, falls es noch Probleme gibt, wir können nachher noch ein bisschen Arduino basteln.
Bad Company 2 macht auch übertrieben Bock. Bad Company 2 ist so ein Spiel, das macht alleine Bock, weil du kannst alleine übelst was reißen. Aber im Team macht es noch viel, viel mehr Bock.
Also ich hab' noch keinen Battlefield gesehen, wo du einen Server so leer ownen, so leer ficken konntest, wie Bad Company 2. Das Wort ist jetzt nicht übertrieben. Wenn du ein gutes Duo warst und Heli fliegen konntest, kommst du extrem ab. Das war in Battlefield 3 und 4 auch so. Aber wenn du mit nem ordentlichen Squad gespielt hast, Bad Company 2, die haben keine Sonne mehr gesehen, die Gegner.
Das war der größte Own aller Zeiten. Ah, Endgegner-Time, wie es aussieht. Okay, Endgegner wissen wir ja. Easy as fuck. Das sind die Endgegner, easy, wenn man Ultimate am Start hat.
Das ist ja schon fast unfair mit den Ultimates die Gegner zu killen. Die Endgegner zu killen.
Aber egal, ich brauch' kein 3 Minuten Boss Fight. Ach, da unten ist das Portal, da geht's zurück.
So jetzt können wir hier hinten durch, das war ja verschlossen. Jeder Boss Fight wächst schreckt. Read Codex in Menu. Oh, die Story. Ja, das hat mich schon immer mal interessiert, die Story.
Ich find mein cooles Story Bob emote nicht. Wer interessiert die Story, was soll im Game?
Da gehen wir jetzt rein, würd' ich mal sagen. Auf geht's. Das sieht nice aus. Äh, okay, kein Secret.
Das sieht hübsch aus, richtig cool gemacht. Also, die haben nicht so viel versprochen, dass wirklich jedes Level komplett anders ist. Von Gegnern her, von Architektur her, von Design her, das sieht komplett anders aus als das letzte.
Der Schrei. Okay, X. Achtung. Nice Jump.
Die machen ganz schön der Marke schief. Alter, ich hab mit dem Fabian so viele dumme Wörter uns ausgedacht. Manchmal kommt das noch so durch.
Ja, als wir Halo gespielt, als wir Halo gespielt haben, haben wir immer, weil das ja der Master Chief ist, haben wir irgendwie immer, weil wir Damage gekriegt haben, gesagt, der Marke Chief. Keine Ahnung warum. Einfach nur hängen geblieben.
Nein, das war kein guter Fight, ich muss es nochmal machen. Wenn man nämlich einen anlasert, dann explodiert der und, äh, hat sich der Gegner gerade in Abgrund gerollt? Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich glaub der Gegner hat sich nach Abgrund gerollt. Ich will es jetzt nochmal hinkriegen, ich will den splattern, dass der zweite mitsplattert.
Jetzt BÄÄÄN. Jawoll, so muss das sein.
Die sind schnell. Bestimmt Microsoft KI. Microsoft Translator KI, die wir gestern gesehen haben. Oh, das war so cringe oder der Livestream von Microsoft.
Jetzt wollen sie, jetzt sind sie aber fies hier die Gegner. Man hat wenig Mana.
Was? Gibt es hier vielleicht nochmal eine ordentliche Waffe? Ah ja, hier, nice.
Da ist ein Power Up. Da ist auch ein Power Up. Kommt man hier dran? Ah ja.
Aber das Design und so, ich finde das ist echt hübsch das Game. Guck mal, da gibt es einen Staff. Staff.
Oh ne, G hat jetzt alle funktioniert. Jetzt Trink vergleichen.
Ich glaube diese Trash Mobs, die kann man schön auto aimen.
Jetzt bin ich gerade so dumm reingerannt, wie ich auch immer in Reinhard Flame Strikes gerannt bin. Einfach komplett sinnlos.
Oh, da gibt es gleich mal die OP Waffe. Huge OP.
Wir haben hier halt zu viel Mana. Also ewig rum spammen können wir hier nicht.
Ist schon schwieriger geworden, ja ein bisschen. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass viele das Game tatsächlich ziemlich schwer finden.
Vor allem Leute, die nicht moveen. Whoa, Spray Modus Activated.
Spray Modus Activated. Easy. So war das wahrscheinlich nicht gedacht, das sollte ein bisschen schwerer sein.
Sonst ist hier nichts.
Da war ein Schlüssel drin. Gehen wir mal runter. Wo das Schlüssel war. Wo das Tor zum Schlüssel ist.
Max schreckt alle weg. Da hinten ist was wie ein Tor. Nee, ist es nicht.
Hier hoch.
Okay, die Gegner moveen jetzt auch mal zur Abwechslung. Au, au.
Grünes Mana ist knapp.
Aber das Level Design und die Optik und so finde ich echt schick.
Und wisst ihr was auch cool ist, dass das was ich bei einigen modernen Games so ein bisschen vermisse ist.
Du weißt was passiert. Du hittest den Gegner dreimal mit der gleichen Waffe.
Der macht seine komische Sterbe Animation. Du weißt genau, du musst gar nicht hingucken. Der explodiert jetzt.
So Treffer Feedback geht mir bei manchen modernen Games so ein bisschen ab.
Nee, da kommen wir her.
Ich fand auch im letzten Doom war das Treffer Feedback nicht so richtig da an vielen Stellen.
Du hast die Gegner mit der Shotgun getroffen. Das hat jetzt nichts passiert.
Oder mit dem Granatwerfer getroffen. Das hat nichts passiert. Bis er dann irgendwann umgekippt ist.
Dann kommt da nicht das neue Doom. Das ist doch auch demnächst soweit sein.
Die machen jetzt doch schon ganz schön. Die machen ganz schön Damage die Jungs.
Kommen wir hier 25 Leben nach so einem Fight.
Gibt es hier vielleicht ein bisschen Leben irgendwo?
Ich hab doch Life gesehen da hinten.
Huge Life. Erst mal speichern bevor wir darüber springen.
Ja, richtig. Genau, das ist wie in den alten CoD Teilen gewesen.
CoD kriegt das Mittel immer noch gut hin.
Wo soll ich das zerstören? War es die hier? Nee, was ist da?
CoD kriegt das mit Treffer Feedback eigentlich ganz gut hin. Da weiß der immer was Sache ist.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Ich hab zwar Playgobs 4 ein bisschen gespielt. Das hat am Anfang auch wirklich Bock gemacht.
Mehr als ich gedacht hätte, aber das hielt keine zwei Wochen. Dann hat mich das Game nur noch abgefuckt.
Das ist ganz schön MonkaS hier, würde ich normalerweise nicht langlaufen. Aber egal.
Solo Mode.
Gegen diesen schnellen Gegner ist der Auto-Aim-Stab sehr praktisch.
Da oben.
Warum triffst du mich und warum treff ich dich nicht?
Was du?
Huge Wizard.
Wo soll ich hin? Immer da.
Hat ich gedacht, pisse ich alle.
Erstmal geteabacked.
Ach Nicky, habe ich überlesen. Kann ich die Variable aus der Funktion denn für den ganzen Code verfügbar machen?
Ja gut, du kannst eine globale Variable machen.
Was unter Arduino okay ist.
Die Arduino Dinger sind immer relativ kurz und übersichtlich.
Da ist globale Variable nichts verwerfliches. Kann man machen.
Runtergefallen.
Und weg. Man weiß immer genau wie viele gegen aushalten, das mag ich.
Nee, er bastelt Arduino Zeug was. Da ist globale Variable nichts verwerfliches. Kann man machen, jeder.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wo ist was aufgegangen, aber offensichtlich da.
Ich dachte, man wird zerquetscht, aber wird man nicht.
Es geht.
Jetzt werden sie geohnt.
Oh nice, beste Waffe.
Die können ja richtig Jumpen. Und Damage machen.
Die trifft man auch nicht gescheit. Der Auto-Aim-Stab muss ran.
Easy Auto-Aim-Stab. Easy Auto-Aim, easy live.
Und auch wichtiger, easy Klimaanlage, easy live.
Also hier fighte ich nicht, hier renne ich mal durch. Wenn ich hier drauf anfange zu fighte, falle ich runter.
Ich dachte, hier kommt, äh, äh, äh, äh, war keine so gute Idee. Okay, ich muss doch fighten auf dem Weg.
Auto-Aim-Stab, auf geht's.
Auto-Aim-Stab, kein Ding.
Easy as a fuck.
Das Movement hier, huge Movement.
Äh, oder auch nicht.
Es macht übelst Bock, das Movement.
Okay.
Also ja, es macht Bock, aber man kann es auch verkacken.
Easy health, easy live.
Zack, zack, zack, zack. Bam.
Boah, jetzt hat sie durch den Portal gerissen, durchgetackert.
Oh ne, du bist aber heftig am casten.
Am besten, am besten ist es für sowas Pastebin oder sowas.
Pastebin kann man mittlerweile auch direkt in Code C++ formatieren lassen.
Die Dinger können nix, die sacken einfach mit dem Auto-Aim-Stab drauf.
Ups.
Was will der da?
OP-Waffe einsammeln, äh OP-Waffenladung einsammeln.
Auch mehr OP-Waffenladung.
Secret, nein.
Da so Secret-mäßig aus.
Ich bin gerade in der Luft.
Einfach mal, wie der letzte Movement-Loop darstellt, gerade ausschießen.
Das funktioniert aber nicht.
Äh, lopp.
Ich hab ne Idee, wir nehmen das Schwert und schlitzen die.
Erstaunlich gut.
Also die kleinen Teile machen richtig Damage, wenn sie einen im Nahkampf treffen.
Umlaufen wir die Seelen mal, vielleicht brauchen wir das gleich noch.
Schlitzschlitz, ja.
Moment, das machen wir mal anders, wir holen mal den Granatwerfer raus.
Granatwerfer mit weg. Weil, da unten gab es Granatwerfer-Ammo.
Jetzt beim Secret, Secret, Secret, Secret.
Sag ich doch, so manche Sachen sehen einfach offensichtlich aus.
200% Life-Secret.
Oh, die werden schön beschreckt mit dem Granatwerfer.
Auto-Aim.
Was soll das eigentlich sein? Schlangen, oder?
Das ist halt Schlangen.
Weil die zerplatzen, die werden halt zu Stein zerplatzen.
Irgendwelche.
Spiders. Nee, Spiders sind das eher nicht.
Schön wegsprayen, Auto-Aim, Staff.
So muss das sein. Sind wir nicht Mana?
Schlüssel.
Wegsprayen, wegsprayen.
Alles dauernd. Eats. Und mein Mana ist weg.
Unser was verpasst, Mana. Jetzt geht es hoch zum Schlüssel. Schlüssel.
Und dann zurück.
Witztags am Start.
Der Movement-God ist am Start hier. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Nee, da kommen wir her.
So viele Souls zum Aufladen, da haben wir gleich wieder Ultimate-Fähigkeit am Start.
Wir sind auch schnell oben. Einfach hier um die Ecke und hochgejumpt. Die Geats.
Manchmal rede ich ziemlich zusammenhangloses Zeug, kann das sein?
Komplett random Bullshit eigentlich.
Das kann Moka Omega sein. Jetzt geht es nicht weiter. Hier geht es weiter, Schlüssel.
Am schlimmsten ist mit dem Fabian zusammen, da reden wir beide nur zusammenhangloses Zeug.
Was machen wir gegen den am besten? Erstmal hier hoch. Lass mich hoch.
Neuladen. Schwert. Schwert hat es bestimmt gut dagegen.
Moment. Granatwerfer, beste. Ich bin sozusagen Planetwerfer.
Gehaut. Gekockt. Schaut euch den Boden an, wofür braucht man...
Also die kommen die Lichteffekte und so haben sie wirklich cool gemacht.
Das ist übrigens Unity 4. Das Game.
Hat da wer sein Gamecube ausgepackt? Das sieht so aus, allerdings ist das Game eine Woche alt.
Geht nicht weiter.
Schauen wir einfach mal runter.
Jetzt ist es aber mal gut. Jetzt ist es ja mal gut.
Nee, so nicht. Spray-Modus ist angesagt. Komm her, komm her.
Besser? Easy. Weg ist praying.
Seelen aufsammeln und fast wieder neue Ultimate am Start. Oder? Ah, nicht ganz.
Aber Mana.
Also optisch ist das Spiel wirklich hübsch. Also vor allem halt durch die Architektur vom Level.
Und dass sich jede Welt komplett unterscheidet, wie wir bisher gewesen sind.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt erst die dritte Welt. Aber wir sind quasi in der dritten Welt.
Wo ist man schon mal in der dritten Welt? Außer vielleicht in Afrika.
Aber es sieht wirklich sehr unterschiedlich aus. Und ich denke, es wird auch so bleiben.
Irgendeine Empfehlung für den Steam-Cell, ne?
Ich hab mal geguckt. Zu null, ja ey.
Ich hab mal geguckt, aber am Anfang war irgendwie nichts dabei, was mich groß gejuckt hat.
Huge prefire.
Gehen wir auf den Keks, die Sacken.
Auto-Aim-Start-Muster an Start. Dann sind sie alle easy.
Alles ICF mit Auto-Aim-Start.
Wo genau geht es hier jetzt lang? Also man muss schon sagen, optisch macht das echt was her, ne?
Auto-Aim-Start.
Ich hab immer noch den Overwatch-AD-AD-Spam drin.
Oh, da kommt ein... der Wizard kommt hier. Angestellst.
Stells Wizard.
Alles down? Hopp. Jetzt ist er down.
Zack.
Oh fuck, da ist noch was.
Checked.
Gehen wir lang runter?
Also der Morgenstern ist so die beste Waffe bisher, gefällt mir richtig gut.
Macht mega Bock.
Ich weiß nicht, der Morgenstern ist eher der Messerstern, oder? Der klopft ja nicht, der wirft ja.
Au.
Wo bin ich jetzt hier gelandet?
Äh, Moment, da ist ein Schlüssel? Da müssen wir nochmal hoch. Den Schlüssel müssen wir bestimmt im...
im Runterspringen uns... uns... uns schnappen.
Oder auch nicht.
Ob das so gedacht ist, wie ich das mache? Ich hab ja jetzt das Gefühl, eher nicht.
Ne, ne, ne, das ist bestimmt anders gedacht.
Den Schlüssel, den Schlüssel kann man überhaupt nicht erwischen von hier.
Tschüss Mc... Mc...
Mc... Mc...
Oh.
Ach, hier kann man das Zeug hochfahren lassen, verstehe.
Dann muss ich die einfach hochfahren lassen.
Und dann geht man hoch. Ne, die bleiben nicht lange noch oben.
Erstmal alles gegen die Wand getackert.
Hier so ganz schlau werde ich außer Sachen nicht. Ich muss auf jeden Fall den Schlüssel holen.
Jawoll, Schalterrätsel.
Oh Gott, ich bin schlecht in sowas.
Die zweite, welcher Schalter löst die zweite aus?
Das ist die erste. Das ist die zweite.
Ne, Moment. Welcher Schalter löst die zweite Plattform aus?
Hier? Ne, der da, der, der, der, oder? Ne, der hintere löst die zweite Plattform aus.
Okay, der hier löst die zweite Plattform auf.
Alter Falderr. Der da. Das ist der richtige. Das ist unser Mann hier. Der löst die zweite Plattform aus.
Warten wir nochmal bis das Ding wieder runterfährt da hinten. Falls es überhaupt runterfährt.
Okay, okay. Also ich glaube ich weiß was ich machen muss.
Ich war zu langsam. Aber von der Idee her passt das.
Von der Idee her passt das. Wir müssen.
Alter, ich check's nicht. Hast du das programmiert? Na klar.
Jetzt aber.
Okay, wir müssen den hinteren, wir müssen den da drücken.
Moment, ich hab ne Idee. Vielleicht müssen wir das anders machen.
Vielleicht müssen wir das anders machen. Wir drücken den zuerst.
Weil der braucht ein bisschen. Wir drücken den zuerst. Dann drücken wir den.
Und dann springen wir hier hoch und dann kriegen wir's.
Easy as a fuck.
Auto Amp Staff. Über die Range können die Dinger eh nichts machen.
Ich hab grad Schlangen gesporn. Wozu?
Ah, Spiders. Nee, nicht Spiders. Was hab ich eigentlich mit Spiders?
Die Dinger sehen nicht mal ansatzweise wie Spiders aus.
Auto Amp Staff und Abstand halten. Es ging das Zeug am besten.
Da können sie nämlich nichts machen.
Wir können das Ding ja mal axen.
Nice. Das brauchen wir nicht. Wir haben schon volles Mana.
Oh, wo geht's hier lang? Super Secret.
Das war hier Super Secret. Nicht einfach nur Secret.
Die Witztards wieder. Die werden genagelt.
Huge Movement.
Goldene Schlüssel. Ist hier der Schlüssel? Ach ja, hier kommen wir ja her.
Was ist hier? Da unten ist der Schlüssel. Moment, Moment, Moment. Wartet mal kurz, Leute.
Alles weggesprayt.
Ja gut, wir müssen ja bestimmt durch das Tor, wo wir gerade einen Schlüssel für gekriegt haben.
Was ist das? Desorientierte Haie.
Natürlich desorientierte Haie. Nice. OP Waffe gefunden und runtergefallen.
Ganz toll. Kann man die abknallen von hier unten?
Das so sein soll? Das so sein soll, dass man hier, also erstens warum ist Wasser hier über mir drüber? Warum kann ich durch den Boden Haie abschießen?
Man weiß es nicht. Ich wollte was trinken.
Wollen wir das Mana? Ne, dafür renn ich jetzt nicht runter. Bisschen Mana zu crammen.
Jetzt müssen wir Schwimmen sorgen.
Da kommt ein Haie. Da kam ein Haie. Der hat nicht lang rumgeheilt.
Da kommst du aus dem Rohr raus und auf einmal gleich so ein Ding ins Gesicht.
Oh, das hat die eine als die andere genagelt.
Das sind die dicken Wisserts.
Da brauchen wir unseren Granatwerfer.
Oh, da kann man durchschießen. Was soll das?
Da kann man durchschießen. Das finde ich jetzt nicht gerade fair.
Ein bisschen schlecht hinmanövriert. Einfach mit diesem komischen Messerwerfding ordentlich hitten.
Und schon sind sie genagelt gegen die Wand.
Wir haben es über Gok gekauft.
Ich glaube den müssen wir lasern.
So einfach kann es sein.
Ich meine das Leveldesign ist schon cool oder? Das sieht schon echt nice aus. Sieht zwar ein bisschen verwirrend, aber man muss sagen es ist gar nicht, also es sieht verwirrende aus als es ist letztendlich.
Es spielt sich eigentlich so ziemlich straightforward. Und ich glaube man kann die Levels auch auf ziemlich unterschiedliche Art und Weise lösen.
Also je nachdem wo man zuerst lang geht.
Ach so tut es wieder. Gegen die ist der Granatwerfer gut.
Alter das gibt es ja nicht. Warum falle ich den da jetzt runter? Vielleicht doch, weil er hier zu fighten hat man mehr Platz.
Das ist ja auch sehr klassisch.
Deswegen habe ich den Sylphio gesehen und dachte das muss man spielen.
Niki hat einen ganzen Code gepostet. Wir können uns das nachher mal angucken. Ich mache das Level noch fertig und dann machen wir vielleicht noch eine Runde. Also Niki wenn du nichts dagegen hast können wir uns dann im Streben nochmal wenn das Level vorbei ist nochmal da einen Source Code angucken.
Und falls noch irgendwas nicht funktioniert können wir ja schauen ob uns da was einfällt.
Aber ich glaube ich muss da runterspringen.
Wo ist das Viech? Muss ich mit meiner Ultimate noch treffen?
Und nächste Ultimate am Start.
Das ist Aluino, das ist C++.
Oh fuck, ich dachte ich kann ausweichen.
Jetzt haben wir ihn aber gegen die Decke genagelt.
Ich glaube der Auto Aim Stab ist gegen die immer noch am besten.
Da kann eigentlich überhaupt nichts schief gehen. Einfach Auto Aim gut ist.
Und jetzt machen wir es so wir rennen einfach durch und die ownen wir wenn wir oben sind weil viel besser als auf diesem komischen Hall.
Huge Movement. Geh weg. Scheiß Viech.
So jetzt sind wir oben Quick Saving und sprayen sie einfach mit dem Auto mit dem Auto Aim Stab zu. Da können sie nichts gegen machen.
Beste Taktik.
Die anderen Viecher sind kaputt.
Wie sind die jetzt gestorben die anderen Viecher?
So wo geht es weiter?
Auto Aim Stab. Der Auto Aim Stab erscheint mir ein bisschen OP ehrlich gesagt weil man kann einfach von den Gegnern weg rennen und rückwärts auf die Gegner drauf sprayen.
Scheint mir ein bisschen OP irgendwie das Teil. Und es macht auch noch ganz gut ganz gut Damage der Auto Aim Stab.
Wahrscheinlich ist es als übelste Loot Waffe verschrien in dem Game.
Auto Aim Stab. Guck das ist übelst OP der Auto Aim Stab. Einfach sprayen die treffen einen nicht und Auto Aim Staben.
Das Übel ist easy easy as a fuck. Und die treffen auch noch nicht mal. Außer ich renn halt voll rein.
Okay doch so OP ist es doch nicht weil wir haben nur begrenzt Mana und wir haben nicht mehr viel Mana.
Also ganz so OP ist es doch nicht. Aber hier gibt es wieder Mana.
Oh was ist das?
Können wir eigentlich auch mal mehr einsetzen? Das ist unsere Instant Kill Waffe.
Was?
Wo kommt denn der Dude überhaupt her?
Hier holen wir mal kurz ein neues Life.
Er will vorbei. Vielleicht kommt jetzt schon der Boss.
Circle klingt irgendwie ein bisschen nach Boss.
Oder auch nicht.
Okay Leute. Ich glaube wir gucken uns jetzt gerade noch mal kurz den Source Code von Niki an.
Und danach muss ich mich mal kurz ein bisschen pausen machen.
Ich bin das nicht mehr gewohnt. Wie lange bin ich denn schon am Start?
3 Stunden. Ich bin das nicht mehr gewohnt 3 Stunden am Stück zu spielen. So schlimm ist es schon gekommen mit 2019.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Au. Alter warum stelle ich mich denn gerade so an? Das kann doch nicht sein.
Ich habe zu viel Auto-Amster abgespielt.
Jetzt genau früher waren die Hände aufgewärmt nach 3 Stunden.
Cross-Auto-Amster.
Huge Soul habe ich aufgepickt.
Den sammle ich nicht auf. Ich habe noch mal ein Power-Up.
Da haben wir gelernt einfach Abstand halten und Auto-Amster.
Ich muss mal gucken ob es noch ein Ultraschwer-Modus gibt. Weil sonderlich schwer ist es nicht ehrlich gesagt.
Aber es ist schon hartdifficult.
Wenn hart schon nicht so sonderlich schwer ist, dann kann Super-Hard ja eigentlich nur noch schwer sein.
Wisst ihr was ich meine?
Also wenn Super-Hard nicht wirklich Super-Hard sein, sondern halt ordentlich.
Ja. Köpfchen ja.
Moment ich komme ich her oder?
Mit dem Auto-Aim-Stab sind die Witztags-Bubels einfach zu killen. Einfach ein bisschen im Kreis streven.
Was macht man hier eigentlich?
Das Movenen fühlt sich aber echt gut an.
So wo sind wir denn schon gewesen? Das haben wir doch nicht.
Wo ist jetzt was aufgegangen? Hier?
Wo ist jetzt was aufgegangen? Nee hier waren wir schon.
Da kommen wir her.
Da!
Was ist das mein Lieblingswaffe in dem Game? Das fetzt so richtig. Genau.
Simple Geometry ist das hier.
Das ist hier Brigitte.
Lass mal ne Runde Goats gegen die hier spielen.
Spielt man eigentlich noch Goats in Overwatch? Ich habe ja schon ewig da mal gespielt.
Ich habe auch nie richtig Goats gespielt. Da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Was macht der da oben? Kann das sein, dass der da einfach von meiner Waffe dran getackert wurde?
Ja und Bunker. Bunker ist wahrscheinlich alles Tanks oder sowas.
Ich kenne mich da nicht mehr so aus. Ich habe lange nicht gespielt.
Bunker würde ich mir sowas vorstellen wie keine Ahnung. Reinhardt, Orisa, Zarya.
Bastion, Orisa. Irgendwie sowas. Das ist bestimmt Bunker.
Torb, Mercy. Man spielt allen Ernst Torb, Mercy.
Wenn die Viecher mal verrecken. Auto-Elmstab geht immer.
Jetzt werden sie geslicet hier. Die ruhige Musik dazu passt eigentlich gar nicht richtig.
Es fehlt nur noch irgendein Kirchenchor.
Move mit Gott wieder am Start.
Jetzt wird es wieder Zeit für unsere Spray-Attacke.
Easy.
Erste Fackel. Wollen wir noch mehr? Zum Glück haben die keine Auto-Elm-Shots.
Der Sound in dem Game ist aber auch ganz gut. Die Musik passt jetzt nicht direkt so gut zu dem was passiert.
Aber die Waffen sind auch so. Ich finde das alles sehr nice gemacht.
Ich glaube das ist auch kein Spiel von irgendeinem großen Studio oder so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein einzelner Typ ist, aber es ist kein Deichs oder so.
Auto-Elmstab, wenn nichts geht.
Jetzt habe ich alle mitgekriegt, das Battle Royale ist jetzt Out. Auto-Chess ist jetzt angesagt.
Also Battle Royale Hype vorbei. Jetzt ist jetzt der Auto-Chess Hype angesagt.
Geht aber auch an mir vorbei.
Was ich noch viel lustiger finde ist, oder worauf ich jetzt darauf warte ist, dass Crytek dann auch noch ein Auto-Chess-Klon rausbringt, wenn es schon wieder vorbei ist.
Das hat Crytek bei MOBAs geschafft und es hat Crytek bei Battle Royale geschafft.
Die bringen immer Games raus, wenn der Hype schon vorbei ist.
Der Auto-Elmstab ist eigentlich richtig OP. Du musst nichts machen, außer ein bisschen hin und her laufen.
Die Gegner hinten dir nicht und du kannst dich schrecken.
So, wir laufen jetzt hier hoch und dann machen wir erstmal Pause und gucken uns nochmal kurz den Zorn-Squad vom Nicky an.
Lass den Auto-Elmstab erstmal regeln.
Nee, da laufe ich jetzt einfach mal hoch.
Was gibt denn das hier jetzt, wenn es fertig ist? Also außer einmal Auto-Elm im Kreis laufen.
Soll ich da irgendwie durch diese Bubbles durchschwimmen?
Das könnten wir eigentlich auch nochmal irgendwann spielen. Ich hatte übelst Bock auf das erste Bio-Schock.
Bio-Schock, wie die coolen Leute ja sagen.
Bio-Schock
Wo geht's lang?
Schafft.
Also das Level gefällt mir nicht. Das ist zu Auto-Elmstab lastig.
Du kannst alles easy mit dem Auto-Elmstab finishen und wegrennen und hast genug Mana. Das Level gefällt mir nicht.
Also dieses hier, die davor waren nice.
Kommt ein neues Bio-Schock? Das frage ich mich auch.
Also auf ein neues hätte ich auch Bock.
This game good.
Schwimmen, schwimmen, schwimmen.
Ja Infinite ist schon lange her.
Hi, hi, piss dich.
Noch mehr Heie. Was geht mit den Heien eigentlich ab? Warum moveen die so gestört?
Das ist die LSD-Heie. Was ist das?
Da spackt da oben noch ein Heie rum.
Da spackt doch noch ein Heie rum.
Alter kannst du mal hier raus? Kannst du mal raus?
Wo ist der Heie?
Auto-Elm.
An WB. Nicky wir haben noch nicht geguckt, aber wir gucken jetzt klar.
Ich glaube wir sind jetzt auch schon so gut wie durch.
Optisch haben sie es wirklich hübsch gemacht.
Optisch haben sie es wirklich hübsch gemacht. Aktuell sieht man hier gerade relativ wenig.
Aber ich meine, was wirklich gut ist, es gibt keine grau in grau Levels hier.
Moment, wir müssen mal unsere OP-Waffe nehmen.
Ich finde ein bisschen viele.
Was? Die OP-Waffe hat nur einen von den Fischern gekillt?
WTF?
Die OP-Waffe killt den halben Bildschirm normalerweise.
Okay Leute, wisst ihr was? Wir machen jetzt einen schönen Schluss und gucken uns nochmal den Zaußkorn von Nicky an.
Okay.
Pepega-Board, habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Empfehlung für den Steam-Sale, nein habe ich nicht.
PC2, Bad Company 3, Refuse warten, ja. Also Bad Company 3 werde ich wahrscheinlich wie der besten Ressens auch blind kaufen, richtig dumm.
Also, okay Nicky, gibt es jetzt irgendwas, was nicht funktioniert, was wir uns angucken müssen oder einfach nur so, wie es so ist?
Also wenn es richtig ist, du willst irgendwelche Sachen an MQTT schicken oder empfangen, müssen wir mal schauen.
Ach, hast du nur reingestellt, okay. Du hast einen ESP8266, alles funktioniert? Achso, dann gucken wir nochmal kurz drüber, was es da Interessantes zu sehen gibt.
Du kannst übrigens mit dem, falls du SSL verwenden willst für deinen MQTT, geht das auch relativ einfach. Du kannst einfach anstatt dem Wi-Fi-Client kannst du den Wi-Fi-Secure-Client verwenden.
Dann kannst du SSL direkt, musst du nichts mehr ändern, außer Wi-Fi-Client durch Wi-Fi-Secure-Client austauschen. Dann kannst du 8883 oder so SSL MQTT machen, falls du willst.
Auch bei deinem eigenen Netz nicht unbedingt.
Last Message, Message, Pong, Channel, Ping. Okay, wo ist, das ist ganz schön viel hier. Wo ist hier Setup? Setup, Connect zum WLAN. Ja gut, das ist genauso wie gesagt, Delay, Print.
Ja, das mache ich auch immer so. Ich mache auch irgendwie immer Punkte hin.
Es gibt übrigens eine Methode, du kannst einfach fragen, Wi-Fi, Wait for Connection oder irgendwie sowas gibt es jetzt mittlerweile. Da kann man sich diesen Gleifenkram eigentlich sparen.
Ich mache es auch meistens so, local IP oder ja, leuchtet ein. So, Client, Set Server und Callback. Ah, okay, ich sehe, du willst per MQTT nichts verschicken, du willst was subscriben.
Dann geht es hier oben rein, in den Callback, wenn ein Message kommt. Warum funktioniert das überhaupt? Du machst du überhaupt kein, im Setup überhaupt. Ach, in der Loop machst du dann Reconnect, ach so.
Genau, MDNS, wofür MDNS? Client Connected, Reconnect. Das ist mit Sicherheit die schönere, die schönere Schreibweise. Du könntest allerdings auch das hier machen.
Client Connected oder Reconnect. Das wird auch funktionieren. Da kann man sich das IF sparen. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall lesbarer.
Kleinen Loop, genau, Last Message. Ja, das mache ich auch meistens so, dass du nicht jedes Mal Pufft-Dings rausschickst. Man könnte es auch mit einem Timer machen, aber das ist doch eigentlich recht ordentlich alles.
So, und wenn man was kriegt, also du verschickst alle zwei Sekunden, alle zwei Sekunden verschickst du hier ein und ein halter Welt.
Und dann machst du Ping-Pong. Und Ping-Pong macht, IF ping gleich ping und dann check.
Was? Patrick, ich finde das trotzdem nice. Also was ich immer ziemlich verwirrend finde zu lesen, für dich wahrscheinlich nicht, weil du es programmiert hast.
Wenn man in Funktionen, wo man eindeutig abhängig ist von ein paar Variablen, wenn man die in globalen Variablen und nicht in Parametern hat, da weiß jemand nicht, wo man gucken soll.
Ping gleich gleich Ping. Zum Beispiel, wo kommt Ping in dem Fall her? Ping wird wahrscheinlich im Callback gesetzt.
Achja. Ping wird im Callback gesetzt. Und was antwortet das andere Ding dann da drauf?
Du willst quasi gucken, ob irgendwie einer in das Out Topic was reingeschrieben hat, entweder Ping oder Ping-Pong oder sowas.
Aber insgesamt sieht das vollkommen brauchbar aus. Das hier sieht übelst hackmäßig aus. Ich weiß, das habe ich ja auch noch gesagt.
Aber das sieht irgendwie eklig aus. Ich weiß, ich habe es vorgeschlagen. Das kann man wahrscheinlich noch schöner machen.
Man könnte bestimmt, weil das ist ja C++, man könnte bestimmt sagen, Rika, das da, das wäre wahrscheinlich die schönere C++-Variante.
Naja, aber ist es verständlich? Was willst du jetzt genau damit machen? Also wozu ist das? Willst du gucken, ob irgendwelche Keep Alive Messages kommen?
Oder ob irgendjemand anderes in diesem Topic irgendwas publisht? Also wofür ist es letztendlich da?
Ich habe noch Fragen im PP-Gerb-Board. Ausautomatisierung, ok. Ja, da bin ich ja auch am Wursten.
Ok. Ja, für sowas sind die ESPs, egal ob es ein ESP-2866 oder ESP-32, sind die Dinger richtig gut.
Willst du das an der Batterie betreiben? Nein, du stopfst das per USB irgendwo dran. Was hast du für ein Board?
Ich meine, wenn es ein ESP-3266 ist, wahrscheinlich ein NodeMCU oder ein D1-Mini, vermute ich jetzt mal. Oder was hast du für ein Board?
Haben wir beantwortet, haben wir beantwortet. Ja, das Game ist neu, das kam erst seit drei Tagen oder so raus, oder in einer Woche.
Funktionieren eigentlich SQL-Injections? Nee, funktionieren hier nicht. Oder hoffe ich zumindest nicht.
Ach, das. Ja, das ist ja glaube ich mehr oder weniger ein NodeMCU-Nachbau, oder? Oder ist das das kleine?
Ist das das kleine blaue oder das schwarze?
Das haben wir alles schon beantwortet. E-Mail. Ah, der Sebaro ist gar nicht mehr da.
Was sind deine Aufgaben, wo du so arbeitest? Ausrufe, Zeichen, Beruf. Wir haben mittlerweile ein eigenes Kommando für Programmierst du heute?
Ich mache jetzt erst, ich gehe jetzt erst mal duschen. Ich mache jetzt erst mal auf und vielleicht, vielleicht machen wir danach noch ein bisschen Programming.
Aber dann.
Hallo Ende 2020.
So, haben wir alles beantwortet. Ah, das Pepega-Board funktioniert wirklich gut. Da geht noch was. Ja, ich gehe jetzt erst mal duschen und danach machen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen Programming.
Der Eichler ist auch am Start. Ja Leute, je nachdem wie ich den Bock habe, ich glaube schon. Ich glaube schon, ich glaube wir machen danach noch ein bisschen was.
Wir machen danach tatsächlich, als wenn der Nicky hier schon heute am Start war mit Arduino Zeug. Ich glaube wir machen danach auch ein bisschen Arduino Zeug, weil ich wollte mal ein bisschen Multithreading ausprobieren auf dem ESP32.
Was sagst du eigentlich zum Community TS? Ja, wird gemacht. Ich kann aber noch nicht sagen wann und ich weiß, dass ich das schon ewig erzähle.
Ja. Nicht TS. Schwachsinn. Discord meine ich. TS. Nee, nee, nee. TS mein ich nicht. Discord. Community Discord. Das erzähle ich seit Ewigkeiten schon.
Ähm, Patrick und Sebaro, macht mal. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ihr könnt ja auch, ihr müsst mir das insofern nicht übergeben. Gebt mir einfach Atmenrechte drauf und behaltet eure Rechte.
Ich meine, ja. Ist doch gut, weil ich brauche eh Leute, die da ein bisschen gucken, was da so ist.
Ähm, alternativ. Ich hab ja nen TS, äh nen Discord schon seit Ewigkeiten mal gemacht. Da gammel ich halt mit dem Fabian aktuell rum. Vielleicht können wir den umfunktionieren.
Ja, kann sein. Okay, ich geh jetzt mal ne Runde duschen und dann machen wir wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen Arduino Zeug.
Ja, das ist der normale GoG Launcher. Weggegockt werden die Games da. Warum hat Microsoft diese komische Shake-Animation sich eigentlich ausgedacht, indem man Fenster minimieren kann und wieder maximieren kann?
Das ist total bescheuert. Okay Leute, bis gleich. Wow. Passt. CU.